[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka tony stank
and though episode seven of one division
is coming out tomorrow
they've actually just released a new
clip of it on good morning america
but rather than doing a full breakdown i
thought i'd just react to it and then
kind of go through it bit by bit and
point out some of the things that we can
take from it
again breakdown coming tomorrow so don't
worry but this is just a couple of
minutes long so it's pointless me making
a full video for it
because i'm lazy anyway enough of me
talking absolute rubbish
let's get into the clip
we've all been there mom are you coming
down soon
mom our game is freaking out
you know
is she asleep mommy's not sleeping honey
she is just resting her eyes
mom my head feels weird it's like
really noisy i don't like it
resting her eyes
as punishment for my reckless evening i
plan on taking a quarantine style
staycation
who don't mention quarantine all day too
soon
just myself that'll show me
it must have been a good night yeah all
right
division debuts tomorrow on disney
i like that guy it was a good night so
yeah let's go through that again bit by
bit and kind of point out some of the
details in it
[Music]
okay so that's obviously when everyone
was running for their lives as the hex
was expanding and they all got turned
into clowns
which could be a political comment on
the police uh if you if you're
that way inclined but very very
interesting to see it all expanding
and uh yeah so obviously one is
regretting this and kind of remembering
what she did
but yeah nice
okay and a little interesting thing
there about the bed sheet is that
those look like hexagons uh and there's
hexagons within hexagons
and they're all kind of connected and
joined together now i was actually
reading a graphic novel recently called
avengers dissembled
disassembled it might be even be called
i can't read i'm illiterate that's why i
stick to comics
um and in that it was at the start of it
anyway there's
a character called anna who's very much
seen as the queen
and she basically runs things as almost
a bee colony and can control people
through her mind
and they do talk about hexes in that
which is quite interesting now though
that's not specifically related to
wonder
in that graphic novel it does sort of
tie in with house of m
and as i was reading i was thinking oh
you know maybe this is the
what the heck's actually symbolizes that
everything's sort of a beehive
and it's all connected in this one mind
under wonder because she sort of gives
the stories and narratives to people
and i don't know if it's intentional or
not but that's just a similarity i
noticed and then
seeing this hexagon imagery on the bed
sheet again it kind of reinforces that
point
mom are you coming down soon mom our
game is freaking out
okay and they're wearing um very similar
colors
to speed and wiccan so you've got the
green for speed which is
typically his sort of color um last week
he was dressed as quicksilver but
when you go to the comics this is more
sort of in line with what he wears
and wicken's obviously wearing the red
black and blue
and that is definitely just his his
color set so nice little set up there
and this is obviously referencing modern
family as well
the couch looks very similar to that and
just the the way it's sort of shot with
a whole
sort of documentary style or
mockumentary
getting a lot of modern family vibes
here
oh game gamecube controllers i remember
those
other there might be wee ones i don't
know if they've got wires on them
i'm a bit old i'm 32 so if things have
changed since i was a kid
apologies
and i think those are those are more
sort of my my age group
those look like atari ones but i never
had one because i was too young
so let me know below terrible video as
always
[Music]
and the uno cards yet we can all relate
to the uno cards
you twist it you switch it back you kids
are going to have some fun with that
that is a good game for twins
is she asleep mommy's not sleeping honey
she is just resting her eyes
mom my head feels weird it's like
really noisy okay so his head feeling
weird there
that might mean you know that might have
deeper implications there's a lot of
people who think that billy and tommy
are going to be taken away
as soon as the hex closes down i
personally don't i think that wonder
will actually
take them out the hex and that vision
will remain behind
and she'll sort of go on the run with
them um
and that'll kind of lead into doctor
strange too in the multiverse of madness
but very interesting there i don't like
it
resting her eyes
as punishment for my reckless evening i
plan on taking
so this is obviously the the
mockumentary style that they've kind of
been going for
and throughout sitcoms in general you
kind of started in the 50s and 60s where
it was very traditionally shot
uh you know characters weren't aware
that they were in the sitcom and we did
kind of see that evolve over time and
then malcolm in the middle came along
and i know it wasn't the first one to do
but that was very much focused on
characters breaking the fourth wall
and you kind of hit this point where i
think creative team
members were kind of like we kind of
don't know how to go beyond this because
we've broken the fourth wall already so
what's the next step
and they did introduce this mockumentary
style which allowed for characters to
break the fourth wall
but it also kept it in line with the
plot so people could talk to the camera
and have a really good time and give
give their thoughts give what they were
feeling
but you weren't taken out of it because
why why are these characters aware that
there's an audience watching them
it's because they're in a documentary
now so well done
quarantine style staycation a whole day
just to myself that'll show me
very interesting there um if you look
closely you can see
wonders pillow has a unique pattern on
it
whereas visions has the hexagons on it
still
so maybe that's kind of showing she's
above all and not really
part of the pattern or the hive as it
were and
visions pillow being like that that
makes me think it is
and i tell you what people you're
watching it live you're watching how i
watch episodes and pick easter eggs out
live
so appreciate that yeah i'm letting you
behind the curtain
the thumbs up buttons there and the
subscribe ones right next to it
and there's obviously a hair costume
from the night before so i'm guessing
that this is at the start of the episode
this is this will be the first time we
see wonder in this episode so
it very much will likely i'm getting cut
from the the end of last week
um similar to how the quicksilver reveal
was where it just kind of cut
dropped in the next thing you don't
really know exactly what's going on
and wonders still got a costume on from
last time
vision's not in the bed whether i've
just realized yeah that's
so he obviously didn't come home and
he's out there still somewhere the
heck's expanded to save him
and he should be somewhere around ellis
avenue i think which was named after the
president in ireland three
bit of trivia for you there but that's
quite interesting so this is probably
the first
episode that they haven't been together
at the start which
shows that they're starting to fall
apart a bit
must have been a good night i love her
i hope he's in the episode as well
anyway great great little
uh i'm gonna leave him on screen because
i like the guy
great little episode well great little
trailer there lots of things to pick
from it got me very excited for tomorrow
i'll obviously be up first thing giving
you the full
breakdown but let me know your thoughts
below on what you thought of the whole
thing is there anything you notice that
i didn't because
god knows i missed so many things
especially with these stupid glasses on
and yeah i'd love to hear it thanks a
lot take care
and i hope you have a good day and see
you tomorrow much love
you